[Music]
so welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started it's this special uh
series of podcasts and versions of my
origin story podcast called just getting
started with voices of the nfl where he
had al michaels joe buck who
my next guest is quite familiar with
because she's been working with him for
damn near a full decade uh on the
sidelines of some of the best games that
we get to see all week thus america's
game of the week
among other items the hyphenate aaron
andrews good to see you aaron andrews
how are you
good how are you it's it's just every
time i see you it's always like god we
don't see each other enough we don't i
see you're a producer he lives across
the street from me i don't know if you
knew that who's that tall producer oh
he's his he's his nickname is the giant
because he's so tall and andy greg of
nfl network yeah he produces
he's the same siciliano is next door so
yeah
that's an episode of twins that's nfl
twins as a matter of fact right there um
so again like
this pod is you know a little bit
different and i know you've got your pod
and we'll talk about your calm down
podcast with karissa thompson and you're
you're aware by ea because that's the
hyphenate that i'm talking about but i'm
i want to get into how you got started
in your career because i'm sure you must
get a ton of people saying how can
they get on a path to where you are and
where you have been how did you aaron
andrews just get started on your career
i just think it was you know the
relationship i had with my dad my dad is
a newly retired investigative reporter
from the nbc affiliate in tampa florida
and uh growing up in san antonio before
my dad
went up the ladder to tampa we were in
maine and we were in san antonio and my
mom was a school teacher monday through
friday and my dad worked the weekend
news and he had me during those
five days and that's where every i
learned everything about grocery
shopping with your dad making him
uncomfortable in the feminine aisle uh
the female aisle and then uh you know
the stories about his favorite teams the
green bay packers the red sox and how
they broke his heart every year the
boston celtics and magic and larry being
best friends my dad is such an
incredible storyteller that i fell in
love with the way he told those stories
and with the guys and the players and
the coaching staff and um i just there
was no doubt that i was going to do this
growing up and i i had said that to my
dad at a very young age i said dad i
want to do that when i grow up and he
said aaron everybody wants that job when
they grow up um and not that he was
pushing me away from it but he just was
kind of wanting me to be realistic but
once i got into high school i mean
that's really what i was telling people
i was gonna go do and when i had to
choose well i'll be honest i didn't have
to choose a certain college i don't know
if i would have gotten into many i
wasn't going to leave the state of
florida i i would have gotten into
florida state i know it but i really
wanted to go into florida to florida
because i felt like they had a great
football team and i wanted to be around
it my dad just shook his head and
thought oh god come on i need you to
want to do more than just go to football
games on saturdays but i said no dad if
the football team is good they're going
to be covered by you by espn they're
going to be covered by cbs on that you
know scc three o'clock 330 kick so i was
right spurrier um was amazing to me at
football practice and had some always
fun comments for me and i i love the
head ball coach because of that and yeah
as soon as i
left college i didn't i had some job
opportunities but it was a lot of
one-man band will make you an executive
producer in in a small uh you know kind
of town in texas and then maybe put you
on air and my dad just kept saying no if
you want to be on air you've got to
apply for an on-air position
literally the night before i got my
first job i was in a huge fight with my
parents i was living with them and my
mom's like you gotta do something you
gotta go work apply an outback
steakhouse would you you can't sit
around all day
and i got my first job
so let's take this one at a time here so
growing up around so you're growing up
essentially around a tv station right
watching watching
local news get put together and hanging
in a control room right like that's the
sort of
upbringing you had being around your dad
and
you so you were watching him what did he
do was he i know you you referred to him
and you're in your twitter account as
clark griswold and stuff like that i see
all that stuff yeah so your dad was
literally the the guy who was on your
side
by making sure right like who was on
your side making sure that the people
who were getting built the people were
getting called out local news that's
what your dad did like knocking on doors
and stuff like that
yes
yes and i mean this guy up until i mean
he's in his late 70s now we were like
dad you're not in your 40s and he is the
guy that's charging the people out of
the car i mean my dad is loved in tampa
but he's also really hated in tampa as
well he and it wasn't just your hotel's
dirty your restaurant kitchen is
disgusting you'll get the flu no it was
like your county officials are screwing
around on your time and on your tax pay
ooh i sound like my dad's promo and uh
we're gonna learn more so yeah my dad
was major i think he's got like over 10
emmys which i'll never get especially
when i'm going against michelle tafoya
every damn year jesus um but yeah no uh
he's amazing so yeah that was my
upbringing well if you want to cry
rivers about losing emmys you know uh
once once once costas actually seeded uh
many of his stages um then there's ernie
who you know very well from turner so um
you know but it's all good it's great to
be nominated i have learned how to say
such a thing um and believe it um so so
then you go to florida
and how do you get a gig covering the
gator football team do they have like a
tv station there is that they had was it
a newspaper what was that like yeah
student-run tv station at goodall weimer
hall and i auditioned to do that and you
know when you start out you're going to
the other sport you're not going to
cover the florida football team you're
not going to cover the florida baseball
team and at that time our florida soccer
team was kick-ass i mean we had abby
wambach on our team so um that was
really exciting but yeah i i think
somebody called in sick one night i got
to hold the mic at gator practice and it
was a hundred degrees and
hbc the head ball coach looked over me
and he goes who are you
and i was like i'm aaron andrews and i'm
you know here to get your you know
comments and he was like aaron and then
he went into a whole thing and from
there we just had this oh
my god this is me out of dazzler
practice with hbc i can't even handle it
head head ball coach that's what that
stands for yeah he doesn't like old ball
coach he doesn't like that at all so hbc
and you were simpawtico right from john
and who was the quarterback there at the
time who is it what year was that
we had well danny of warfall was my
freshman year and then noah brandeis i
mean knock it off and then sexy ruxie
rex grossman and jesse palmer who oh my
god what a what a string of quarterbacks
what a string for for the hbc to come
through and
oh my god and now you you know at some
point you you all had different roles in
the abc disney universe at some point in
time all all of you guys pretty much all
right so then so then you graduate and
and it's because for me
i remember when i i got out of michigan
i worked at a stu on my hometown
newspaper
and i just wasn't cut out for it and i i
i had to
why well um
in the same gene
or dna that your dad had to like knock
on doors and find out what the hell was
going on with this story that was a
problem in the community um i didn't
have that set of cojones to be honest
with you i'm being very honest like i
remember
one moment aaron that i was on duty and
this was back in the day in the early
90s when there were no cell phones
and so the main reporter and main
uh columnist and reporter she was out on
assignment and a major story broke where
one of george
bush senior's thousand points of light
who was a a principal in the red hook
section of brooklyn and he was a
a knight in shining armor who would
knock on doors and tell truants you're
coming to school
he got caught in some horrible crossfire
and was murdered and it was my job i
know
so the editor was looking for the main
reporter she was out you eisen
go to their house and get a comment from
the family
and i thought to myself what like like
people i don't know and i've never met
at their worst moment of their lives
and they're
i'm like some
some i'll say some [ __ ] showing up on
their front door
asking them questions like for comment
how do you feel what how do you think i
feel like i was so afraid to do it oh i
procrastinated erin i i i um
i sharpened every pencil that was there
i looked for the right you know
reporter's notebook
i just was like i couldn't i was in a
sweat
and then you know to her credit the main
reporter returned
just in time before i left she was told
what the story was and she heel turned
and ran right out
and i didn't hold any i didn't look at
her in any less regard
at all
i just wasn't up to it
and i i had that moment i'm like i am
and i know like
i just realized i'm not cut out for the
hard news i need
i need the toy department you know
you know that and that's what
and that's what my my professor at the
madill school of journalism um called it
when i was there
uh because that's where i went back to
school i went back to northwestern i'm
like i want to be a sportscaster i got
to i got to figure out how to do it
and and so that's why i i wasn't cut out
for it and i i got into that and when i
was out of school there i
i had to go anywhere that would with
that for the job and a camera and a
newsroom that would that would give it
to me so i totally understand your dad's
saying you cannot take a job that you
don't
need you need to take a job that you
need you do not need to go and hope for
the best that some news director is
going to see something and you know you
want to be on the air you take an on-air
job that's a great piece of advice from
your dad which you obviously know today
yeah and you know it's twofold too
because it could have opened the door or
something and i know people like that
you know my good friend and colleague
chris thompson started at hr at fox and
was hoping to just get on the air but my
dad's thought was look i work at a tv
station we hire on air talent to be on
air we don't hire producers hoping
they'll get on air so um i was i was
grateful for that insight i'm glad i
listened um he's kind of been my roxanne
moment behind the scenes for me whenever
i'm in crisis or
uh you know i last-minute post-game
interview i'm like dad what do you think
of this
right and now uh so what what where was
that station that hired you where was
that tv station so it actually was a
it's a route that i highly recommend a
lot of people do now it wasn't even a tv
station i was the ringside reporter for
your tampa bay lightning they were
god-awful um they had just fired a new
head coach john tortorella who was going
to turn the country club around um
fourth line contained a guy named marty
st louis who ended up being a superstar
once torts got done
and it was a huge learning experience
for me all i knew about was the florida
gators that's all i cared about that's
all i had studied for four years that
was another piece of advice my dad gave
me he said listen i get it that's the
first thing you read when you go to the
sports page but there's a lot of other
things going on in the sports world and
florida football so you better start
educating yourself and lo and behold i
got thrown into a league i knew zero
about i mean i the i've told the story
before i read cliff notes for dummies on
hockey like i just did hockey for
dummies the night before
my first interview with them and
tortorella is not known for suffering
any fools at all did you have any
moments with coach uh tortorella in the
beginning of your career
at all i did he did not want me hired by
any means and i get it i was you know 20
21 out of college this like i said was a
team that had zero success they weren't
expected to have a good year they were
actually out of it by december the year
i worked with them and um
one of the guys that was big with the
organization that had pushed for me to
get the job just said now that you got
it i recommend you go to his office
right now knock on the door introduce
yourself and be very honest about your
knowledge about the game and i did and i
walked right up and i said hi torts if i
can call you torts um i'm aaron andrews
i don't know a thing about hockey but i
am willing to learn and from that moment
on i sat and watched film in his office
and i learned how to cuss i learned what
happens on the road stays on the road i
learned to drink pretty well i not from
torts but just traveling with the team
because at 21 i was traveling with this
professional hockey team and i was on
their flights i was on the bus i sat
right next to him on the bus he made
sure of it it was awesome and i learned
um he said if you if you it's like you
hear this all the time at airports if
you see something say something he said
to me say something ask me if you see it
and i noticed one of our big players
wasn't in the pregame skate that morning
and nobody asked torch so i raised my
hand this was probably four or five
months into the season and i just said
towards
so-and-so is missing and he looked at me
and he goes great [ __ ] question
and i was just like
yeah so
he he taught me to kind of have a
backbone and um it was awesome now that
you're
much more well-versed in the sport
since hockey is literally
part of your life have you seen have you
seen tortorella many times since then
and just like talking about these
moments now where you are in your career
and
and the the the 21 year old who sat next
to him on the bus and knocked on the
door you had conversations about that
with him
big time i mean i
the
half it wasn't even the lightning
weren't even through with their season i
had already gotten a job offer from
turner sports and we were on a five game
road trip in canada and my dad was on
the phone with me
with his agent as well with turner who
had offered me the gig and my dad just
said this is national tv this doesn't
happen you you're five months in you got
to take this
so i remember getting on the plane the
lightning were terrible they were out of
it and i just
walked up to the front of the plane and
i was bawling and i just said i got a
job offer to go to turner sports to be
on national television my dad wants me
to take it i don't want to go and he
goes you better can take it and he goes
in if you hate it you can come back to
the sunshine network and be with the
tampa bay lightning
cut two i took it we can talk about that
whole experience i was god-awful turner
i was so bad um i was with skipping joe
in the studio i was just brutal but
that then led me to not my two-year
contract or maybe three-year deal i
think those two i wasn't renewed and i
shouldn't have been i was horrible and i
don't think i was put in a good position
and even charles barkley will tell you
that which i love him for
i then
uh auditioned well kind of threw myself
at espn's nhl coverage because
um the lightning were going to be pretty
damn good in o4 and it was the
postseason that i wasn't renewed and i
had kind of an audition with them and it
went really well and lo and behold the
team i was following all throughout the
playoffs was the tampa bay lightning and
that little girl who was crying in the
uh on the plane was getting like the
coach head coach to tell her all the
gossip so he was like feeding me the
intel for my sideline reports and it was
freaking awesome well i mean tommy's
everything and that that does actually
happen a lot in in the in this career
is that you know
if you're
you have some certain insight on a team
and that team becomes red-hot yeah um
that's
to your benefit i mean you know and
that's that's where you can use you know
your knowledge and your institutional
knowledge and all of that so
um
what was it was i i was just leaving
espn when you got there i know i don't
even think i really got to see you there
which was such a bummer so 04 was kind
of my audition and then i got put on the
05 coverage of football yeah okay
yeah
i was gone yeah nfl network started
november of 03 my last day there was was
may of may of 03 and we were like two
ships so what was your first college
football game tell me was florida was it
was it the was it the uh the hbc
you know
no i was put on what was that game oh it
was huge and again i probably wasn't
ready for it but i appreciate them
throwing me into the deep end
it was
uh
virginia tech meeting usc and it was
that game that espn did where it was
behind the scenes everywhere like you
could see what the producer was saying
to me um i was with uh ron franklin and
we were in i think we were in baltimore
um my god your first broadcast was that
was like a special one where yeah where
they're
where oh my i could not imagine
because you know a producer a producer
for somebody who's not done it before
needs to kind of coach somebody up and
you've got to feel comfortable so oh my
god your first broadcast was everybody
listening to how you were receiving
information and disseminating it is that
what you're saying from the truck my
first espn college football broadcast
was yes and i will tell you this i
remember and the footage of it is
excellent my they did a jib shot of me
as my open
my legs were so far i was like in a like
stance like a tripod stance so far apart
to like give me like grounding i
probably was white knuckling the mic but
my legs were like
because i was just like oh my god
crap all right well then obviously
things progress and um
so uh i'll i'll i'll throw a question at
you that uh i get all the time and you
could answer it however you see it but i
get it all the time literally to this
day 18 years removed why
why did uh you leave espn why did that
parting happen
aaron
it was time um and i probably called you
i don't even remember if i did i called
a lot of people about it um it was just
time i felt like i had done everything
that i was going to be allowed to do
there
um and
i wanted to really be a part of the nfl
i had done you know this sounds so
bratty i had done three or four and you
know championship games i've done
college game day and i just knew if i
was going to have a shot at the end i
felt it was going to be at fox so i i
i cried my eyes out my god i remember
talking to chip kelly balling my brains
out because i covered him a lot at
oregon he was wonderful i talked to
coach k um i called him for advice i
talked to dan patrick quite a bit
and um yeah i just was like what do i do
and it was hard but um
yeah well yeah it's gone pretty well i
should say so i should say so and um
which was your first nfl game because it
took you did college for the first
couple years right so then well
my first nfl game i oh god it was a
playoff game this is ridic i mean you
can how many deep ends of the pool have
you been thrown into
my god
i mean
i will tell you i think well i know it
was this because i had covered russell
in college russell wilson who is a baby
in the nfl it was when russell wilson
played rg3
in the um
in the playoff game and rg3 ripped his
leg up
i think that but i had i had seattle
sideline well i i i it
makes perfect sense i mean russell's
first year
uh in the nfl was 2012. so this would be
2013. i'm almost sure of this
20 2013. literally
and it was seattle at fedex field and
rg3 tore his his leg up and he was you
know it was him and andrew luck one two
yeah and i knew both of those guys
from covering them in college so it was
crazy because i remember
aikman asking me and it was just so you
know amazing to be with troy and and pam
and joe and aikman being like what are
these guys like and i was like well let
me tell you i know him
it's the same thing you know in the
tampa bay can become big and you're part
of a nhl coverage like i got this
you know i mean
yeah i'm literally trying to find this
on here because i know i took pictures
you still have it on your phone from
back in 2013. that's okay
you know i mean because it is it is i
remember that i remember that and
russell damn near almost made the nfc
championship game and
he he did the uh nfl game day morning
sunday morning uh championship game
weekend
there it is look at you with him
both of you look how young he is
it's i mean i am just i'm national and i
say that without most of respect i mean
it looks like i'm i'm i'm not the fine
line that obviously um
you know you are but so no and all in
all seriousness i mean i remember
russell
showed up to game day morning
to do the show and he'd never done
television before
and um i'd like to pride myself on being
the first in
uh on a sunday morning certainly for a
big championship game broadcast
and you know my my call time yeah at 4am
for 415. it's gotten a little later in
uh in the years that i've done that
sunday morning show and who was the guy
in the green room
who is already suited and booted and
ready to go
when i walked in the door you know in my
civilian clothes but russell wilson
and and here's a great story
i mean i'm like damn man way to show up
the host just right away you know
and after you know um
he did my first ever television version
of my podcast which was born into the
show i do every day and the reason why i
tell you this is because he appeared on
it i asked him to appear on it because
he was that rookie
that had suddenly won the job from pete
carroll in his first time at it
and um i had him on because when have
you ever heard that a rookie is drafted
as late as he was drafted given an
opportunity now he's the starter of the
seattle seahawks and i had him on he
sent me a handwritten thank you note and
an autographed jersey
and and i'm like whoa hell is this guy
and when i saw him there sitting there
i'm like well perfect opportunity for me
to thank you for this you i mean he's a
he's one of one that guy
russ you know
he is and and
you know our
history goes back to my first thursday
well not my first his third first
thursday night game on call you know
espn college football nc state i had it
i think it's the first drive he got put
in an ambulance he got knocked out so
you know i'm we have a researcher that's
chasing the ambulance it was just like a
whole thing and then of course he went
to wisconsin i follow him in wisconsin i
think my dad and i were at when they
used to do this uh the white house
correspondents dinner together i always
took my dad as my date and we were
sitting in a bar in dc watching the
draft and my dad's like god i just want
russell wilson to get chosen because you
covered him so much at espn and lo and
behold he did and
we've had some oh i did his podcast and
we talked about it it was my first nfl
game i covered him we covered you know
it's just crazy how we're kind of just
intertwined it's really neat and then
obviously um
potentially your most famous moment on
the job
even to this day
was
the post-game press conference with
richard sherman yeah and i want you to
walk me through that i don't think i've
ever asked you about this really dan was
calling me the next day trying to get me
on his damn show oh you know what that's
dan dan dan you know there is an iron
rich in eisen but i'll get you know i
give people space i'm like dan
that's why dan is who he's dan dan and i
go way back to 1996 and i could fill
your head with all sorts of stories
about dan patrick but he is they broke
the mold with him too
um so uh what what what the hell
what i mean how did you because that is
something you can't no matter how many
reps you've had no matter how many years
you've had no matter how many places
you've been to no matter how many folks
that you have like your dad and your
life there is nothing like that sort of
curveball thrown your way in a broadcast
so walk me through that one aaron yeah i
i covered quite a few seattle games that
year and um i was actually on i wasn't
full time with joe and troy yet i was
working actually with john lynch kevin
burkhart
and pete michelska so we had had the
seahawks a ton and um i ended up you
know really the seahawks are phenomenal
and especially with that time and that
defense they were just really great we'd
go in before the coaches meeting
actually like go to the lunchroom that
they were in and see the guys and be
like a little bit you know legion of
boom like what's up um so
i i love sherman i had had a great you
know i i feel like relationship with him
and the day before the game we had had
our crew meeting with the seahawks and
again another guy troy hadn't met or
that crew hadn't met
was richard and he walked in and he was
awesome he if you i mean i know you
probably
talked to him quite a bit he just lights
up a room he is so well educated well
spoken he just has a great perspective
on everything and um and very
opinionated which i appreciate and it's
kind of nice to have somebody that
doesn't candy coat everything or give
you the thing bs when you're in a
meeting and i love those guys that treat
us and and kind of let us in like that
um and he was very very vocal about
crabtree um we knew that was going to be
the match up and you know obviously
something that broadcasters do when you
sit down with these guys and talk to
them about the matchup what do you think
about it he was very honest how he felt
about michael crabtree so honest
and um we were like
okay
i mean
brutally honest so we already had
insight there was bad blood there
already knew about it not something we
were gonna go on air and say hey there's
bad blood because it's just not like
that you don't want to sit there and you
know rat a guy out for telling you
things but we appreciated the insight
that was the final you know match up
that was the play i
knew i wanted to grab him he had just
done a deportes interview so i was
basically holding on to him because i
knew they were going to come to me live
and i didn't want him to go anywhere
and then
the question sucked that i asked take me
through that play i just just at what
why when where how what you know i don't
even know at this point but um what was
your mindset that's crap too whatever
i
my face which i want to smack in that
interview i i have nothing against
sherman that interview
my face is at that point
holy [ __ ]
this is the biggest thing i've ever seen
in a post game interview guys do not do
this i know exactly where this is coming
from between he and crabtree
what is my next question going to be
because everybody is watching this and
this is going to go viral this is going
to be insane so at that point
i knew he was screaming don't you ever
talk to me like that again and i knew he
wasn't talking about me but i didn't
know if people at home knew that what
the hell was going on right so that's
why and i wish my freaking face hadn't
looked like that i wasn't like who was
talking about you i knew but
don't do it with that face idiot but i
was just trying to calculate my head oh
my god how do i ask this and is this the
right or place to go with all of it
so and then crabtree
and i at that moment everybody in the
truck panic they thought maybe he had
dropped an f-bomb they wanted to get out
before he did drop an f-bomb i was ready
to go for another question
i'm pissed i didn't just go for it why
wouldn't i go for it it was the most
important interview at that time i threw
it up to jill like an a-hole i was like
oh joe back to you like
it wasn't my best moment but i thought
it was awesome what happened with him so
you
can't watch this back without being
hyper critical and
i guess that that would that would cover
it
so you can't watch that back
um without saying i would have handled
it
a million different ways if you had got
if you get it right now if that happened
to you coming up on this
this playing season for you yeah i'm not
mad at my question i'm just mad at my
face and through all of it we were
watching it kind of all unfold
as soon as that game ended i we got up
on a plane and and we were all together
it was myself michael strahan the
president of fox sports kurt medefie
were all flying back to la together and
no one really knew that this happened
like everybody jumped on the plane and i
just started watching it on twitter
unfold and it was turning into racist
and i just looked at everybody on the
plane i said i need help like i love him
and that's i think it's my reaction that
caused this
and this is not what it's about this is
freaking awesome that he did this
and um no i don't think i did him any
favors and i'm bummed about that and i
loved that moment i was so pumped that
an athlete
reacted like that
um i just wish i had done a better job
well he had just i sort of you know had
gone after brady earlier in the season
too after beating new england like you
mad bro like
and and the the brashness of the legion
of boom was just beginning
to take hold nationally and that was a
way for
for richard sherman to kind of introduce
himself to america
in a way and and you were right next to
him
as well and um it really was wild and
you're right the reaction was
um out of control
and
you know um
and i also know he can be really hyper
critical and hypersensitive you know and
and to be in the middle of all of that
man oh man i'd never asked you about it
that's why i wanted to
kind of i got this because i you know
had reached out to him and talked well
actually we did an interview because fox
had the super bowl that year so um i did
a sit down with him and we hugged and
everything was great there was never a
problem with it but at that moment
here's my wheels turning
i'm gonna contact mars candy and tell
them you and i need a snickers
commercial and we're going to reenact it
and i'm going to give you a snickers and
it's going to be fine and i did and they
didn't take it
well you were not at the height of your
influence yet aaron you were just
beginning you still were just getting
started on that
well uh in terms of all that why why did
you start with um your your line of
clothing i cannot imagine what an
undertaking that would be and everything
that you're doing what a headache that
might be and also exciting i understand
and you got fanatics and
and i'm sure you you you know the folks
there well before you even went down
that road but why where where did the
origin of that come from the whereby
yeah just being a huge fan of sports and
you know wanting to support my
my favorite teams and also being as they
like to as the young kids like to say a
wag a wife or girlfriend and uh you know
wanting to represent and celebrate my
husband's team but then maybe go to the
bar or restaurant after and not be a
huge super fan i just felt there was
like a real need for women to be able to
cheer on their fan and have something
fashionable to wear
and uh we were in san francisco for um
not the last super bowl but the one even
before that and we're just kind of of
course it involves alcohol i think it
was super bowl 50. um and we were just
sitting around i started doodling on a
tablecloth and i said could somebody
listen to me about this and i came up
with where and
got a lot of heisman's in our face gotta
told no a lot but i'm pretty relentless
when i think it's a good idea and i i
think it will have a shot and finally
uh fanatics listened and i'm
appreciative of that they threw us right
in the deep end right away that seems to
be the theme of this and said yeah sure
you want to try it try the nfl see how
she goes
and we kicked ass we had a soft launch
and then our sales grew by 200 percent
the second year and then by year three
which is this year we have um
added the nhl to the nba to the ncaa to
nfl and we may have a pretty fun
announcement coming up about another
league so um
yeah it's been really great it is a lot
it's a ton of work i did not go to the
university of florida for any of this
stuff design or business or anything
like that
i hear you it's been really interesting
i hear you you know since you know again
the only thing i can even equate it to
is the show that i'm doing every day
i've i've now owned it since
um since geez january of 2020
and decisions you got to make decisions
you got to have i
i'm not i like i said i i didn't get
into this to to to to run stuff but it
is a challenge there's no question about
right
yeah
um and now your pod with carissa how you
guys enjoying that it looks like every
single time you're having a blast
yeah it's fun i mean it's honestly just
one of our ketchup sessions i mean we go
we really do go in with an outline and
then it just all falls off the rails
it's just like oh my god and listen to
this and now how about this and she's
newly married and i've only been married
for four years we're trying to start a
family she's you know just starting up a
business i have a business and then lord
knows where these conversations will go
once we're on zero sleep and you know
traveling to all these cities in about
three weeks
um so yeah it's fun i mean we kind of
make fun of ourselves we're like
everybody else has a podcast why can't
we so yeah no yeah even i've got one
[Laughter]
you have a format and kind of a like you
know
a beginning and an ad and ours is i'm
trying to have a stride i've got a
paddle you know i got a paddle with the
logo i love it i'm gonna try to yeah we
gotta get you merged
you know i'm trying to get them all
about branding people so um i get the
the one question i've been asking all my
guests on this pod is the best piece of
advice advice you've received and from
whom i'm imagining i know who it's from
since we've based on the a lot i've
mentioned him a lot on your interview uh
in this in this conversation if it's not
your dad it's fine
but the best piece of advice you've
received
in your career and what is it
to impart to people
it's going to be two people one's going
to be john porterella and it was after i
got on a bus one day i mean you'd think
this guy's job was to babysit me it
wasn't it was actually to like get a
team to a stanley cup which he did
several years later i the hot thing at
that time were message boards not blogs
or twitter or instagram and you know i
clicked on something about my nose and i
just came on and i was a mess and he
just said
i'm gonna tell you this once and i'm
gonna tell you once only you gotta have
thick skin you gotta knock it off like
if you're gonna let this crap bother you
right now like this is and it's
something i'm obviously still trying to
work on but it i mean he told me it
before things got really bad with you
know social media and all the things and
my dad we we interviewed our dads on
father's day chris and i did and we were
talking about the advice and chris said
that what's the best advice your dad
ever gave you
[ __ ] him
that's it no it's just it kind of is a
long same line as torts it's like you
can just let all these people in their
opinion and think that they can do it
better and these aren't just people that
are hanging out in their basements with
their cats these are the local media
these are
maybe even national media that have
things to say about you you're just not
going to make it far if you just let all
of this weigh in on you you can't or
wait i mean mentions are the meanest
things in the world and you know um just
in that respect too
erin i got um
i got
i'll tell i mean if you got a minute
i'll i'll just extend the interview and
tell the story here so
when i first started at espn and i did
sportscenter everything to me was a joke
literally everything was a gag i come
from the world of stand-up comedy i was
so excited to be on sportscenter and i
wanted to be entertaining that's what i
wanted to be i was that was first order
well i mean that was the first order of
business
and
you know being um entertaining was more
important than being informative
by far you know like i i lost track on
the reason why people are tuning in is a
to find out what happened and b they're
sticking around because they're
entertained and i had it twisted i had
it the other way around and literally
everything was
a joke and a gag
and um i got one day
and i got to bring this up to him one
day whenever i i do speak to him in this
format but one day i go to my
mailbox at work and you remember the old
inter-office envelopes
okay so it was like this inner office
envelope and i recognized the
handwriting to you know to rich eisen
and i recognize the handwriting it was
from albert
and i open up the interoffice envelope
and in it is a letter from a fan
and a cover letter from keith
and the cover letter from keith
is important because the fan letter that
keith sent to me was an a letter that he
got that was written up on an old word
processor
again this is 1996 and sent to keith
and the message from keith was
this guy that's on sportscenter
fix him because he's ruining it and that
guy was me
and it was like a three-page letter
about me and rhys davis believe it or
not who's the sweetest guy on planet
earth
reason i were doing a lot of sports
centers before i did them with with
stuart but anyway i'm telling you this
story because keith's cover letter
was essentially saying
don't be the guy that somebody is
sending this to
but
understand this guy has no
sense of who you are as a person and has
no personal stake in you which you have
and your colleagues have and he even
said like one day you'll be taking over
this show
and he put in parentheses would next
friday be good for you you know like
there's like a like a ko line like that
and but he basically said
don't take this personally from this
person but hear what this person is
saying
to improve your
on-air
repertoire and
i it was tough it was very tough love to
receive that
from a guy who i was
trying to emulate probably ripping off
was now my new colleague i'm 26 years
old it was really tough to hear this
from him
but the message was in essence [ __ ] him
but you know listen to what he's got to
say on this front but i never
you know
took to heart what the guy said but i
definitely removed from the [ __ ] sort
of aspect of it absolutely and i cannot
imagine
what
somebody a female sees in
her mentions
and what people have no problem being so
twitter tough to hit send on with their
thumbs
[ __ ] them literally i totally think that
is a great
that's my long-winded story to say i i
hear you and i think that is great
information and advice
fact it's it's yeah it's hard because we
do care so much and there's a lot of
hours and days away from our loved ones
we miss holidays we miss everything that
those people have you know the negative
people often they get to spend with
their holidays but there are the moments
and i don't mean to be interviewing you
now that i would love to know what
maybe doesn't validate it for you but
when the bradys say yes to you to do a
sit down in week four or week five
that's where you're just like yes like
bring it or the rogers will sit down
with you or
the mcvays and the peyton's will run off
with you and before they tell you you
know what their team needs to change at
the half they're like how you doing
everything good at home you guys get
like it's just
that's all i ever wanted was the respect
from somebody like you the people i
respect in the business or
the players the coaches the gm's the
organizations when i
hear it from them or i get some sort of
validation that's i mean i do i get
really misty even now about it because
it's just like damn it's paying off
hard work no question about it
yeah
that's the r i guess that would be armor
i don't read the mentions like that
after shows you know or i yeah i i i
have done it before
um
after the night of a draft i don't do it
during a draft but on the night of a
draft i want to see what people are
saying whatever and i once mentioned
that to joe buck and he's like what the
hell are you doing that for
you know and i'm like it's because i
don't hate everybody's team joe that's
why i can look at my mentions like
you know but i i love kind of busting
his stones about that um which is so
unfair my favorite moment and this this
kind of sums it all up as to why
you can't listen to a lot of the noise
then that but i'm not saying that fans
and people who watch us don't have
constructive criticism that's worthy of
taking it's just that you have to
separate that wheat from the chaff and
my ultimate chaff on all this front was
when joe trended on twitter because he
was getting raked over the coals for
calling a game that he was not actually
calling
that i think it was like a yankee red
sox game joe buck's trending and joe was
like yeah i'm not calling this game
folks
and so you know i brought that up to him
that sometimes i do read the mentions
after a big event just to see what
people are saying and what can be what
can be separated from but i don't take
the the anger and the
the personal stuff it's just you know
you know susie takes that one she'll
she'll like you've got to respond like
you have to you have to say something if
you don't i'ma take the phone like no
you can't do it like she's i gotta i
gotta you know i gotta
temper some of that um
but because you know she'll read some of
these things and be so livid about it
and um
it's just you know and i totally get it
i totally understand it but
as you point out the respect is is your
armor the respect you have amongst your
peers is your armor on that sort of
front you know totally grateful for it
yeah my husband came on the sidelines i
think once during a football game and
he's like we're doing that again i was
like he'll come freaking post but he's
like babe i need airflow i can't listen
to what these people are you want me i'm
like
yeah
aaron thanks for doing this i appreciate
it this has been fun um if you you know
if you ever want uh me to do the home
and home with you and chris i'm more
than happy to do that
okay
you just let me know and i'll i'll
return the favor thanks for being on
here and congrats on everything going on
with you thanks and good luck moving
into your new studio are you guys in
there yet yeah or it's it's uh it's at
sofi and you know it's really weird
going to work and seeing this the new
stadium which is amazing yeah it's and
um it's just
weird you know being in one spot um but
you know just that's what i i tell
everyone that i'm a professional flag
planter i planted the flag for the first
day on nfl network and i'll keep doing
it as long as they're willing to awesome
as long as my badge works my security
badge works i'll keep using it that's
always a good indicator if you're
allowed back in
exactly
thanks for the call thanks for doing
this aaron yeah love you thank you you
bet that's aaron andrews right here on
just getting started